c'est une nouvelle drogue venu des
États-Unis le GHB dont l'usage est en
forte progression fait de plus en plus
de ravages depuis 20 ans elle est
surnommée la drogue du viol le j'ai
achevé ça ressemble à de l'eau inodore
légèrement salée une molécule utilisée
comme anesthésique devenu dans des
criminels abreuvage redoutable un
breuvage redoutable car le GHB est
difficile à détecter et et éliminer
rapidement par l'organisme au début des
années 2007 drogue fait des victimes
dans des soirées privées ou dans des
boîtes de nuit l'une d'elles porte
plainte contre son agresseur c'est la
première affaire de viol par soumission
chimique juger en France en 2003
il y a 2 ans cette jeune femme invité un
ami chez elle pour boire un verre
discrètement l'homme verse la drogue
dans son vin le calvaire va durer
plusieurs heures il la viole sans
qu'elle puisse résister
je sentais que je m'endormais et le
réveil c'est comme une partie de sa vie
avec n'existe pas en fait on essaie de
mettre des mots de suite les images de
suis
condamné à 5 ans de prison l'impunité
n'existe plus mais les agressions sous
j'ai achevé continue de faire des
ravages car pour s'en procurer rien de
plus facile sur internet des dizaines de
sites étrangers vente du GHB et propose
même des recettes pour en fabriquer
problème sur le net acheteur et apprenti
chimiste sont incontrôlables et face à
ses agresseurs les patrons de boîte de
nuit tente la prévention à l'entrée des
étudiants à forme les jeunes sur les
dangers de cette nouvelle drogue
quelque chose qu'on donne à des jeunes
filles pour
après parce qu'elle se souviennent plus
de rien de la prévention même si ça peut
un peu casser l'ambiance quelques
établissement de nuit emploi différents
moyens affichage mais aussi changement
plus radical des habitudes de
consommation en deux mots buvait couvert
en d'autres termes mettez 20 couvercles
sur Vauvert
c'est encore aujourd'hui le meilleur
conseil à suivre
[Musique]